foreign
[Music]
well hey you guys time once again for
another tomes of Terror my little book
review series
so I remember hearing a [__] ton about
uh catriona Ward's novel The Last House
on needless Street back when it came out
back in I think it was Autumn of 2021.
um you know there was a really lot of
Buzz about it in the horror community
and I also read that the movie rights
got snapped up pretty quickly so I don't
know what's happening with that though I
don't know if they're gonna make a movie
out of it eventually
um I'm obviously a little a little late
to the party here as usual
um because I will say that like even
though the cover looked really cool and
the brief synopsis of the book that I
read sounded kind of intriguing I
actually didn't get around to reading it
until it showed up on my Kindle
unlimited recommendations for free
because you know I'm kind of a cheat
[__] like that I hate I hate to tell
you so now somehow I managed to avoid
any spoilers or like in-depth plot
synopses or anything like that in the
two years since this book came out and
I'm actually really glad I did as I
usually am because I feel like this is
yet another case of the story being much
better if you don't know exactly what
you're in for now that said this novel
has a pretty big twist I guess that I'm
not gonna spoil
um and that if astute readers may
actually be able to guess it
um it also has several unreliable
narrators I will go that far and I will
say that it also kind of like utilizes a
Trope that has been done in horror
stories and in Thrillers several times
before now I didn't actually mind this I
didn't mind the reveal and some other
readers seem to like it as well because
this is like you know largely a pretty
well reviewed book but I did notice that
some reviewers absolutely hated it so
your mileage is going to vary on this
just like pretty much everything else
but just know that going in now The
Narrative of this is also not entirely
straightforward so it does kind of
necessitate some pretty close attention
to detail like it's not inscrutable or
anything like that I found it pretty
easy to follow despite it jumping from
kind of character to character and time
period to time period which it does a
little bit but you know people who
prefer or maybe more linear story
storytelling might find it a bit
frustrating so also know that going in
so on the surface we seem to be
following this lonely kind of youngish
to middle aged man whose name is Ted
Bannerman and he lives in this kind of
run-down house on the end of this
dead-end street needless Street
obviously
now from the beginning we know something
is kind of off about Ted like he comes
across as extremely
um socially awkward but he's also very
sympathetic but some of his conduct
seems a tad sketchy if not outright
Sinister you know what I mean so even
from the beginning like the reader is
pretty sure that things aren't entirely
as they're being presented now even
though a couple of his neighbors seem
pretty friendly toward him and seem to
kind of like talk to him and try to
bring him out of shell and stuff he's
also had like rocks thrown through his
windows and other vandalism kind of like
perpetrated against him
um because he's seen as something of
like the town weirdo you know what I
mean
um near the beginning of the story
actually this is kind of like a a sad
like a bummer this because anytime
there's anything bad happens to animals
and so you guys know how I get
um but Ted is actually like really
heartbroken when somebody in the
neighborhood you don't find out in later
until later like who did is like very
cruelly hides glue traps in all of his
bird feeders which kind of like you know
kills all the birds that he actually
like loved watching now it should be
noted that some of the reason for the
community's like hostility toward him
has to do with the fact that he was a
suspect in The Disappearance of a little
girl like from a nearby lake several
years previously now he was actually
dismissed as a suspect but people are
still kind of like you know because he's
kind of a weirdo and he's keeps to
himself and everything like that now
Ted's parents are presumably dead
um and he seems to have had a
complicated relationship with them
especially his mom
she was a nurse that immigrated to the
United States from a small village in
France and she had some
interesting parenting techniques to say
the least let's we'll call it that
um so the extent of her maybe like
trauma generating behavior
um only kind of gets slowly unveiled
like as the book goes on like through
flashbacks and stuff now in the present
day it seems like Ted's only friend is a
very devoted affectionate cat named
Olivia yes the cat
um and actually this book has several
chapters written from the cat's
perspective I know that sounds kind of
weird but I mean anybody who knows me I
love cats you know I have three of them
if you're new here uh and I have to
admit that these sections that are kind
of from Olivia's point of view were
pretty delightful I really didn't like
it I was like that's exactly what I
imagine like a cat's thought process
this would be it's pretty awesome
um but I will say that just like
everything else in this novel nothing is
entirely as it appears that's about as
far as I'm gonna go with that now Ted
also has a teenage daughter named Lauren
who is only in the house sometimes
you're kind of led to assume that she's
with her mother the rest of the time
like maybe there was a divorce in the
past or something and she just comes to
see Ted for visits like weekly or every
couple weeks or something like that
um she's disabled although they don't
really tell her tell you what the
disability is until later on um but
she's all she's very rambunctious and um
Ted really like dotes on her but he's
also real over protective
um and he's kind of like attempting to
Shield both her and Olivia the cat like
from the dangers of the outside world so
some of the chapters are also from the
daughter Lauren's perspective as well
however as I previously alluded to
something is not entirely right about
Ted uh he drinks a lot for one thing and
he has pretty frequent blackouts like
sometimes for days at a time in which he
says and does some pretty questionable
things that he doesn't seem to remember
like when he comes back to himself
he also seems to believe that there are
entities of some kind that he calls
green boys up in his attic and he never
actually goes up in the attic he also
spends a lot of time in the woods next
to his house with the gods as he calls
them which are initially undisclosed
objects that he keeps berries buried
like in the woods and that he seems to
like Revere quite highly and like he has
to move them around sometimes there are
also several instances throughout the
novel where Ted
um who's very lonely like I said and
he's kind of longing for human
companionship he will use fake pictures
like to make a profile on a dating site
and set up meetings with various women
um and you kind of see the beginning of
some of these meetings but you don't
actually find out what happens with
these dates until later on now while all
of this is going on with Ted we're also
following another care character whose
name is d
now Dee's six-year-old sister Lulu
vanished from a family trip to the
nearby lake many years ago and has never
been found
now Dee's mother abandoned the family
shortly after this disappearance and her
father I think he committed suicide so
Dee has kind of been dealing with her
own trauma in that regard so the only
purpose kind of like remaining in her
life is to find the person who took her
sister so for many years I mean this she
has been on like a single-minded pursuit
to find this person like since she's
become an adult
um and she also kind of has the grudging
help of this police officer that she
actually I don't even know if they say
the police officer's last name she just
calls her tired Karen so close to the
start of the story like after Dee has
kind of run through this whole laundry
list of suspects and sort of gotten
nowhere and there are actually
references to some trouble she got into
like in Oregon like apparently like
going after some other suspect they
don't really go into a lot of detail
about what happened there but the cop is
just like yeah you don't want to do that
[__] again so I guess she maybe did
something to somebody that ended up not
being the person so she's kind of been
going through suspects not getting
anywhere so then she focuses her
attention on Ted who like I said was a
person of interest in The Disappearance
back in the day but was eventually
cleared of Suspicion so Dee ends up
renting the empty house next door to
Ted's and starts like obsessively like
surveilling him
um and she's basically like searching
just desperately for evidence that her
missing sister is there either dead or
alive so that's like about as far as I
want to go in revealing like plot
details because I kind of feel like the
appeal of this book is in just this
constantly shifting mystery and you know
it's changing perspectives it's kind of
fragmentary
um sometimes almost dreamlike like it's
not surreal or like I said it's not real
like obtuse or anything like that it's
not hard to follow but it does have a
little bit of that kind of style to it
but I mean it's really never less than
uh a very compelling story because like
new information keeps unfolding across
like multiple Avenues and multiple
characters now I will admit that I had
begun to guess what the twist was likely
to be and I was mostly correct when I
got to it
um but that didn't really diminish my
enjoyment of the book overall I mean I
was still interested to see how it was
going to play out how it was going to
resolve itself you know so as I
mentioned before like the the Trope the
twist or everything like that it's been
done a bunch of times before so I feel
like maybe some people might find it
right or disappointing or something like
that but I thought it worked really well
in the context of this story now
although this is absolutely a horror
novel there there's no other thing you
could call it it's also a pretty
fascinating
exploration of maybe like the lingering
effects of trauma and the survival
mechanisms that different people employ
to deal with it you know what I mean uh
you know For Better or For Worse like in
everyone's situation I'm not sure that I
would go so far as to say that the novel
deserved all of the hype it got
um but I actually found it like pretty
engrossing like I was really into it
um and I'm actually sure I'll probably
be thinking about its themes like for a
while so I really did like it quite a
bit so that will do it for this tomes of
Terror I hope you guys enjoyed it
remember to like and share and comment
and all that kind of stuff and I'll see
you guys again on the next one bye